- [Chris] Let's do it.
- Welcome everybody,
another YouTube Hangout,
super pumped to be here.
I've got a new friend with me.
Chris runs a podcast called
The Entrepreneur Hour,
and he wanted to interview
me for his podcast
so I said yes, let's do it.
But how about we also
make it a YouTube video,
so I could expose him and
his ideas to you guys?
So before getting into the questions
and Chris will run into
his intro for his show,
Chris, welcome aboard
man, how are you doing?
- Hey man, thanks for having me.
Good to be here.
- Quickly, for my audience,
just give a little background,
what you do, what The
Entrepreneur Hour's about,
and where they can find you.
- Totally. So, started my first business
from my college apartment,
actually my brother and I,
and had really no intention
for it to do anything
other than just to pay
our bills and our college.
I kind of always was entrepreneurial,
starting businesses when
I was in high school,
even back to middle
school, just lawn care,
and, you know, just stuff that's
outside of the hour for pay model.
Lo and behold, we got traction,
unexpectedly got traction
with that business in college.
We found ourselves scaling
to 1.2 million dollars
within 36 months with that business,
doing operations in 32
states around the country,
working with five of the seven major
furniture turnkey providers.
So I was having all these
incredible conversations
with people, other
entrepreneurs and mentors,
things of that nature, and I just said,
"Man, these conversations are so powerful
"and they're so impactful to me.
"Why aren't we recording
this and paying it forward
"and giving back to the
entrepreneurial community?"
A lot of things that, you
know I always said this,
but if I had known x six months earlier
than when I actually learned it,
maybe my journey would have
been a little bit easier
because truth be told,
a lot of people think
scaling is a lot of fun.
And while it is, it's certainly
it's very, very difficult
to scale at that kind of a rapid rate
in a matter of 36 months.
So, that's kind of how
the show came to fruition.
As you can tell, I got
all my podcasting gear
all set up in here, so I look
like a true podcaster, right?
So, lo and behold, man,
within two weeks of launching the podcast,
we were top five new and noteworthy
under business, health, and education,
and we parlayed that
with some major guests.
We went from, like, 30 downloads a day
when we first launched
in the first couple days
to, like, thousands a day,
and it just has been just a crazy ride
but I think it's been exciting.
It's been exciting to hear
from the entrepreneurial community
and know that they're getting
value out of the show.
And then, you know,
last week I interviewed
Daymond John from Shark Tank,
and so, it's been awesome
for me to connect with those
just incredible entrepreneurs,
people like yourself
that otherwise I wouldn't
have had really an opportunity
to connect with or
maybe just wouldn't have
come to fruition or would have taken me
months and months and months
to find the medium to connect.
So, that's kind of my story in a nutshell.
I'm also now involved
with several endeavors
here where I'm based in the Atlanta area.
- I love it, man.
Well, thanks for the intro,
and turn it over to you,
whatever you need to do for
your podcast, here we go.
- Let's do it.
So, I want to flip the
question on you then.
So, tell me about your journey
and tell me about major life events,
things that kind of led
to what you're doing now.
- So I can give you a high level,
and then, if you want to dig
deeper into any of those things,
let me know.
I'm happier to go further.
Growing up, I never thought I
was going to be an entrepreneur.
I had a lot of entrepreneurial tendencies,
selling art, selling baseball cards,
a bunch of different things,
but I didn't have any
entrepreneurs in my family
or immediate kind of community,
so I thought I wanted to be a banker.
I feel like in my high school yearbook,
where are you going to be in 10 years,
a VP at a bank, it's where I
thought my tracks was going to be.
I go to university, and I'm
on that path to be a banker.
Connect with two
entrepreneurs who need help,
and I join their business
as one of the owners.
And we struggled a lot making $300 a month
and barely able to survive.
I get opportunities to get
those dream jobs at banks,
where I'm earning 80 to 100k a year,
and I decide not to do
those and do this business
that is not making money,
the hardest decision of my life.
And then from there, end up
sucking some more at my company.
Finally find a turnaround point,
and a couple years later, we get acquired.
We can go through that if you want.
From there, I became a venture capitalist,
raise half a million to 15 million
for companies wanting to expand,
and now, started helping entrepreneurs
and had a popular website,
have a popular YouTube channel,
have a book with Penguin Random House
and my goal is to help
a billion entrepreneurs
and that's what fuels me daily.
- Yeah, and I really want to get into that
'cause I think that's awesome
that you have that mission.
And I want to talk to you,
it seems like everything you've done
as far as your branding is concerned
is like your power statement of believe.
So, kind of talk about what that
power statement means to you
and then how important
it is for entrepreneurs
to have that positive mindset.
- So, I believe everybody
has one word inside them.
They have one core value
that makes up who they are.
It's the topic of my book that came out.
For me, it's believe,
and it's more than just
a marketing thing.
I think a lot of people
see, that's great branding,
that's great marketing.
- No, totally, yeah.
- And it is, it is.
It's great marketing,
but it's authentic to me.
It's who I am, it's what I do.
Belief for me comes from my parents.
It's the reason why I have a picture of me
at seven years old up on my
wall with my parents behind me.
They would always teach me that
I was Castrilli Carmichael,
I could do anything that I wanted.
And so, whenever I
didn't do well at school
or whatever it was, got other problems,
the answer would always be,
"You're a Castrilli Carmichael.
"You will get through this.
"You can do anything that you want."
And so, believe a lot came from them.
And I think it's important to understand
what you do stand for and
then start to live that life,
and for the entrepreneurs out there,
bring that to your business as well.
And so, understanding
that I was about believe
and that was my most important core value,
I didn't really know that
until later on in life,
but that now allowed me
to get a turbo charge
into my business, grow a lot faster,
make better content, connect
with people on a higher level,
and also have a lot more
fun, make a lot more money,
feel like I'm doing purpose-driven work
and that allows me to go
out and have a big impact.
- Yeah, so when did you
find the platform of
creating content, doing video,
and things of that nature?
Did you just kind of
stumble upon doing that?
- It started actually on my website,
so the thing that saved
my company early on
was modeling success.
When I realized
I'm not the first guy to
try to do this before,
somebody's already done
it, let me figure out who
and model their success.
That saved from going from $300 a month
to actually having a paycheck
and building a real business.
And so, I modeled Bill
Gates, how he started,
zero to one, I wanted to learn that.
And so, I then built a website
to try to help entrepreneurs
avoid some of the struggles that I faced
early on in my career,
and I shared the stories of
all these famous entrepreneurs,
hoping that people could learn from them.
I was learning myself and others
could learn from them too,
hopefully avoid their pitfalls
and learn from their success.
And that evolved into a YouTube channel
just because I'm much
more of a visual learner.
I would rather see something than read it.
And so, if I could read
Steve Jobs's speech,
that's great, but if I
could see him delivering it,
it just touched me more deeply.
I resonated with it more.
I was able to understand it more.
And so, it evolved to a YouTube channel
because it's much more of a visual medium.
So it started selfishly for me
to learn more about these
famous entrepreneurs,
to continue my, to build my growth,
and I shared it with
others and thankfully,
people have been inspired as well by it
and continue to come back.
- Well, I think it's really interesting
because you talked about
how believe is unique
and authentic to you and how the video.
So, you've created things that really were
authentic and unique to you,
and that's really what's
made your brand take off, it sounds like.
So that's really, really fascinating,
just make it, just be your
best unique self, you know.
- Yeah, and when I first found believe,
I thought it was too
bold, too big an idea,
other people have done it before.
Justin Bieber had his Believe tour,
and Cher had a song Believe.
- I forgot about that, yeah.
- Shamu the whale has a show
at SeaWorld called Believe.
It's been used, and I
think what happens a lot,
especially with entrepreneurs,
is we talk ourselves down
from big ideas.
We'll come up with a big
idea and say this is great,
here's how we can go and
change the world, rah-rah.
And then, the next day,
it's not even our friends
and our family who put
us down, it's ourselves.
We are our own worst enemy.
The next day, you wake up and say,
"That idea that we had, that's too big.
"I can't do that.
"I don't have the resources or
the capabilities to do that."
And we talk ourselves down from
doing the big, bold things.
And so, I didn't want to not do it
because I was afraid of
doing something bold.
I think that happens way
too often for entrepreneurs.
- Now, you talked about your parents.
Were they both entrepreneurial,
entrepreneur driven, or kind
of how'd they feel about it
when you started pursuing
entrepreneurship?
- They are not entrepreneurial at all.
My dad worked for the government,
basically his whole life, and then retired
and became a consultant.
The thing that was great about my parents
were they always encouraged
us to do whatever we wanted.
And they made us feel like we
could do whatever we wanted.
And so, they lived more traditional lives
and I think in part
because on my mom's side,
her parents kind of grew
up a lot more strict
and so, she didn't have the freedom to do
some of the things she wanted to do.
And so, the result was
I'm going to give my kids
lots of freedom and confidence and belief.
And so, I have two
sisters. I'm in the middle.
All three of us went totally different,
wacky, creative paths.
My older sister did a bunch
of Silicon Valley start-ups
and is raising money and CEO
of a new company down there.
My younger sister went
to Africa for 10 years
and worked for the UN.
- Oh wow.
- And is helping child
soldiers come out of
the war zone and helping them
get back to a normal life.
- That's awesome.
- And just crazy stuff.
And so, none of us have led a traditional.
None of us led the traditional
life that my parents led,
and I attribute that to them
instilling that belief in us
that we could do whatever we wanted.
- Yeah, cool, man.
Well, so you talked a little bit earlier,
you talked about helping and inspiring
one billion entrepreneurs,
which is quite an ambitious
feat you're setting out for yourself.
But talk about what the
world would look like,
this is very, kind of
ambiguous or vague question,
but talk about what
that would actually mean
socioeconomically to the world in general.
What kind of impact would that make,
or as you see it or how
you envision it would?
- I think all the world's problems
will be solved by entrepreneurs.
I think it's on us to save it.
I don't think it's going
to be the government
or who the president
is or big corporations.
The innovation happens from entrepreneurs.
And countries, wars are
stopped because of economics,
because there's a lot
of trade that happens,
because it's us doing the work.
And so, I think every major problem,
if you're looking at
healthcare and diseases
or if you're looking at space exploration
or if you're looking at world
peace or whatever it is,
I think it's going to be
solved by entrepreneurs.
And I think a lot of people
have a genius level talent
at something inside them that they're not
ever going to go and do
because they never tried it.
Now, they're stuck doing some menial job
that they don't like.
They hate going to work every day,
where they have something inside
that could really contribute
to the world and not doing it.
I don't know, what's your favorite sport?
- So, watch football, play basketball.
- So, football, who's the
greatest quarterback of all time?
- It's got to be Brady now.
I mean, you can't, you
can't argue with that now.
It's just.
- It's timely, right?
It's timely.
- Prior to that, it was Montana.
I would have said Montana,
but it's got to be Brady now.
- Whether you say Brady,
whether you say Montana,
whether, like, you know, Troy Aikman
or you know, whatever your hometown hero,
I would say it's none of those guys.
I would say the greatest
quarterback of all time
is a manager at McDonald's
because he never actually
picked up a football
and he didn't know that he
had that genius level talent.
And so, you've got Brady,
Brady is maybe number 100 on the list.
There's a ton of guys who
would have more potential,
but they never picked up a football.
And that's what upsets me.
People have a lot of this
untapped genius inside of them,
and instead of going
off and doing the thing
that they could have,
Tom Brady-like genius level talent at,
they're stuck in a crappy
job that they hate,
that pays the bills
and they look forward to
the weekends and evenings.
And so, if everybody, if a billion people
were off doing their thing and showcasing,
like, imagine a billion
people being Tom Brady
at what they're doing,
that's an amazing world
that I want to be a part of.
- Right, and I always think about that
as far as what stops us from
actually pursuing those things.
And if you think about it
in the grand scheme of life,
looking back at it, it's like,
my nightmare is that I didn't pursue that,
not that I didn't accomplish
this, that, or whatever,
but that I didn't actually
pursue my dreams to the fullest.
That's the only way you lose.
That's the only way you fail in my mind.
- Yeah, I think what stops people
is self-awareness and fear.
- Yep, yeah.
- Right? Like I didn't know
that I could be an entrepreneur.
Like I had all these
tendencies growing up,
but unless I met those
two people in university,
I wouldn't have been an entrepreneur.
I would have gone down the banking path.
And so, the self-awareness is important.
And then, the fear to actually
go out and do something,
not just take that idea
you have and sit on it
but to take action,
and one of the ways to combat
the fear of taking action
is the greater fear of regret.
It's the Jeff Bezos regret
minimization framework
that he calls it, where
you're like 100 years old
looking back on your life.
Are you going to regret doing this?
And if you are, then you got
to make an important decision.
And that can give you the courage
to break through whatever
short-term fear you have.
- Right, right. Well, you
act on it, and that's great.
So let's talk then about
so far in your career
as an enterpreneur, what
has been your most proud
or rewarding moment?
- That's a hard one.
I don't celebrate it almost at all.
- You and me have that in common.
- Yeah, honestly I think,
I think high performers
don't celebrate that much.
You look at Tom Brady, you say
greatest quarterback of all time, great.
Won five Super Bowls, okay.
I'm sure he's celebrating
day of the parade,
but what's he focused on now?
- He's already on to the next.
- It's like 2018 Super
Bowl, let's go guys.
We're like five weeks behind.
Let's start training, right?
So I have a tough time with that question
because I don't, I don't know.
I'm proud of a lot of stuff,
but I don't really look back that much.
It's like, okay, let's keep going.
Let's have a big impact.
Let's keep getting better.
- Okay, let me shift the question then.
What has been the most powerful message
that you've gotten from
someone in your audience
or a follower or somebody
that you've worked with
that they've really demonstrated,
man, you've done this for my life?
Is that a bit easier?
- Yeah. I mean,
here's one.
'Cause I get, I mean, I'm fortunate,
I'm sure you're at this spot now too,
where you get a lot, like daily.
It's amazing. You get a
couple hundred comments a day.
And a lot of them are
insane life-changing stuff.
I remember one though in particular.
It was on a video we did, I
think it was Magic Johnson,
the basketball player
and entrepreneur now as well.
And there was a guy who watched the video
and he left a comment and he said,
"My parents taught me growing up
"that black people were really stupid.
"And this video just totally
changed my perspective."
It's like, that's nuts, right,
that something that I'm involved with
is changing people's perspective
on things like racism
and opening their minds to
different points of views,
where you're not just insulated
by your immediate
environment of your parents
and family and community
'cause if you grow up
in a crappy environment,
chances are you're going
to be exactly like them.
And listening to The Entrepreneur Hour
or watching videos and reading biographies
and surrounding yourself
with better knowledge
can help you break free,
broaden your perspective,
and give you the chance to go
out and do something amazing.
And so, that one in particular
stands out as that's,
I mean, that sucks that
they grew up in that.
But how amazing is that
that something I made
totally changed his perspective?
- Yeah, I wonder how old he was,
how long he's been operating
with that limited belief.
- Yeah, and then would
continue it on to his kids.
- No, and yeah, for
generations, absolutely.
That's crazy. That's awesome though.
Alright, so let's shift gears.
Let's talk about where do you take
your efforts from here.
Reaching a billion people, like I said,
that's a pretty lofty goal,
albeit it looks like
you're well on your way,
but what does that look like?
What does the future look
like for Evan Carmichael
and what you're going to be doing?
Is it books?
Is it continuing to build
your video presence?
What is that going to
look like for your entail?
- Yeah, so the billion,
the billion question gets asked a lot.
I think for me, it's not so
much about how do I track,
how do I hit a billion.
It's more that
the work that I do has
to have the potential
to make a big impact.
And so, I don't do one-on-one coaching.
I don't have a hey hire me for an hour
and it costs x amount of dollars.
The work that I do has to be at scale
for me to achieve what I want to achieve.
So, the YouTube channel lets
me have a wide audience.
Doing The Entrepreneur Hour
lets me reach some more people.
Writing a book, like I don't
want to self-publish a book.
I can make more money
self-publishing a book.
I went with Penguin Random House
because that lets me
reach a wider audience.
And so, I think when you see
really successful people,
they are really stubborn about
the mission, the vision, the why,
like, this is what we're here to do.
I am here to help a billion entrepreneurs.
This is what I'm super passionate about
and wake up every day chasing.
The how and the execution changes.
I'm not attached to the how.
It's like stubbornness to the cause,
but extreme humility,
like I'll do anything
to move that thing forward.
If you told me that cleaning out toilets
would help me reach a
billion entrepreneurs,
I would do it.
- Yeah, you'd do it.
- Right? Like, I'm not above that.
I'll do it.
And so many people are like,
I'm not going to do that.
That's beneath me, right?
And most successful leaders,
nothing is beneath them
to help them accomplish that big goal.
And so, I can tell you where I'm going
in the next couple months,
but where am I going to be in five years?
I didn't know I was going
to write a book a year ago.
Five years ago, I would never
say that YouTube would be
where I'm spending most of my time.
So in the next couple months,
it's hey, I'm promoting the book,
I'm getting the YouTube channel going.
It's where I'm spending most of my time
and what I'm in the short to
mid-term super committed to.
In a year, in two years, in five years,
I don't know, but it's going to be
impacting entrepreneurs in a big way,
whatever that looks like.
- Total scalability.
Alright, so you talked about a guy that's
he's a manager at McDonald's
and he could potentially have been
the Tom Brady or even
better than Tom Brady,
make Tom Brady look like an afterthought.
Talk to that guy right
now or that gal right now,
and they're on the fence about,
whether it's entrepreneurship
or pursuing whatever it is
to pursue, what would
you say to that person
to get them to finally
take that leap of faith
or hop over that fence?
- I think it's first
helping them understand
what it is that they want to do.
Does the guy even know
that he can play football?
Has he had any exposure to it?
Do you want to go out
and start a business?
What is it in your head?
Are you happy with your life?
Are you happy with where
you're at right now?
You ask most people that,
they're going to say no.
If they're honest with themselves,
like if it's a total
stranger, he'd be like,
yeah, I'm happy,
but deep down, most people
are not happy with their life.
So, just getting into that
uncomfortable position
where you are analyzing,
'cause instead of actually
trying to fix something,
we escape.
- Exactly.
- Right? It's like.
- No, totally, and definitely.
- I don't want to think about my problem,
so let's go watch Big Brother 18.
And so, just even having the awareness
to have a conversation around,
listen, your life is broken,
you're not happy, you could be doing more,
you know you could be doing more,
let's start figuring that out.
What is that big dream
that maybe you could
start building towards?
And then giving them
the support and belief
and environment to do it.
What often ends up happening is
I would be a blip, right?
Listening to one episode
of The Entrepreneur Hour
would be a blip.
And maybe that's enough
of a blip to spark a fire.
They're just so pent up and
so ready to make a change
that that one episode, that half an hour,
makes them want to make a change.
But for most people, it's just a blip.
And then, they fall back
to their regular habits and
patterns on their environment
'cause they have an
ordinary routine that sucks
and an environment that sucks
and habits that suck.
And so, you need to
have a wholesale change
of your environment.
You need to listen to
The Entrepreneur Hour
every day, repeat, multiple episodes.
Go back and listen to it again, right?
You need to read the biography.
You need to start to
change your standards,
and that comes from
changing your environment.
And so, the most important
thing that I try to get out
when I'm talking to somebody is just one,
the awareness that they
don't like their life
and they're just escaping.
If you can't wait to go on vacation
and you're just escaping your life,
vacation can be great if
you're seeking something
but not just running away
from a life that you hate.
Putting the awareness on that and then
restructuring their environment
to give them new habits
that will support them in thinking bigger.
- Man, I could not,
could not agree more
with what you're saying,
and it's interesting because
you talked about how
many people are unhappy.
I think I read recently,
and I've said this on several episodes,
that statistics found that 85% of people
are currently unhappy with their career
or their career path.
85%, that's ridiculous to me.
And so, it really inspires
me to do what I do
and reach a larger audience,
I'm sure you're the same.
And I think in this day and age,
and I'm curious to hear
your thoughts on this,
but you talked about escaping.
It's never been easier for us to escape.
You can grab your phone and watch,
just watch YouTube videos.
I'm miserable, so I'm just
going to play on Facebook
or social media or
whatever the case may be,
rather than actually deal and
confront your issues and say,
Why am I unhappy and how can I pursue that
so I'm not unhappy?
It's distractibility.
We find things to kind of
take our minds away from those
versus challenging that.
- Yeah, 100%, I also think
it's never been easier
to go and do the thing you want.
- No, absolutely.
- Right? Like, it's both sides, right?
- Totally, totally.
- Yeah, it's easy to get distracted
and bombarded, like yeah,
you're playing your next game
or whatever it is and you're
just lost in your phone.
But at the same time,
hey, The Entrepreneur Hour
didn't exist 10 years ago.
- Exactly.
- Podcasting wasn't around.
And here's this chance to
listen to some great people,
to listen to Chris's insights
and all of his guests,
and you wouldn't have
access to these people.
And so, it's never been easier.
At the same time, it's
just replacing the habit.
Take one thing that you
think is a bad habit
that's just keeping you where you are
and swap it.
Like, what do you do first
thing in the morning?
What website do you pull up?
Is it just some prank
video YouTube channel?
Great, how about you just replace that
with The Entrepreneur Hour every day?
Just make that one small change,
and now you're actively feeding your brain
to try to get better and
build a better environment,
career and life for itself,
as opposed to just escaping
and just laughing at some joke.
- Definitely appreciate
all the plugs, man.
Thank you. (laughs)
So anyways, talk to me,
my dogs are chiming in
and you can hear them.
So we always try to end on this question
with resources that you recommend,
books that you've read that have been,
I know you're an avid
reader from what I can tell
and you've got all these
inspirational people in your back,
so I can tell you have those influencers.
So, talk about the
books that you recommend
people must, must read,
podcasts to listen to,
influencers they follow, and
those that have impacted you.
And then part two of that is
where can people learn more about you,
where can they find you,
the YouTube channel,
the online presence.
Where can they learn more about you?
- Sure.
In terms of resources that I recommend,
I'm, again, much more of a visual learner
than I am anything else, and so,
my recommendation honestly
is my YouTube channel.
I use it for myself.
It sounds like a shameless plug,
but the videos I make of
learning from these famous
entrepreneurs is for me
to learn and get better.
- No, I get it, man, totally.
- After that, I would say I
love Gary Vaynerchuk's content
on YouTube.
I love Lewis Howes's content on YouTube.
Those two guys, I consume
most of what they make.
In terms of books, I'm a weird duck.
Like, I'll consume
whatever I'm interested.
Right now, I'm interested in
adult human behavior change,
and so, I'm reading about triggers.
Triggers was a book I just finished.
Power of Habit is one
that I have coming up.
- That's a good one.
- Power of Habit?
- Yeah, it's a good one.
- Alright, okay, I'm
going to have to move it.
- Duhigg, right?
- I'll move it closer
to the next read list.
- No, I believe it.
The one I'm thinking
about is Charles Duhigg,
and yeah, it's powerful, man.
It's good.
- Yeah, so I'm interested in that.
I think in terms of my
all-time favorite books,
the two at the top for me are,
one is The 4-Hour Workweek,
entrepreneur classic,
more for just time management,
helped me out a lot,
not so much the only
work four hours a week
'cause I believe you got to work on
whatever you're passionate about.
- Definitely, I agree.
- And then the other
book that I really like
is out of print.
It's called Radicals & Visionaries,
and it was, I used to read this
when I was starting my first business.
Every day it's a different
famous entrepreneur
and kind of three to four pages on them,
so you get the hidden motivation
as well as some strategies.
And it's kind of what my
YouTube channel has been
based off of, like to come every
day and there's new content
where you're learning from
a famous entrepreneur.
So, it's out of print, but if
you can find a copy on eBay
or something, it might be worth a read.
Podcasts, Entrepreneur
Hour, go check that one out.
I heard it's a good one.
- Thank you. (laughs)
I appreciate it.
- I'm not a huge podcast consumer.
I don't have a commute.
And when I do, I read as
opposed to listen to something.
So, I'm not a huge,
I think for me, the hearing is the hardest
'cause I'm visual so
I like to see a video.
And if I can't see
video, I need to read it.
When my teammates are reading me a message
that they want me to
give them feedback on,
I need to read it.
Them telling me it doesn't
compute properly for me,
so I think that's probably why
I just haven't consumed podcasts.
But there's a lot of great ones.
But The Entrepreneur
Hour is, you know, guys,
you got to go subscribe to that one.
- I appreciate it.
- Me, wherever you hang out,
I'm mostly on YouTube and Twitter,
but you know, I'm on Snapchat,
Instagram, my website,
the book is wherever you buy books.
It's called Your One Word.
And yeah, just type in Evan Carmichael
wherever you like to hang out,
you'll probably find me.
- Yeah, man, you got
some cool stuff online.
I really enjoyed it.
I was checking it out
when I was doing some research about you,
and actually, I think,
if I'm not mistaken,
that's how we stumbled upon
you, I believe, was YouTube.
If I'm not mistaken, we saw one of your
the top 10 tips for success
by so and so or whoever.
You do like a series on those,
I think that's how we stumbled upon you.
So, I was like, man, this is powerful,
the message really closely
aligns with my message
and stuff like that.
So I was like, alright, we got to chat.
But cool, man, I
appreciate you taking time
to be on the show.
Actually, I've never done at the same time
a live video stream while
I'm recording a podcast,
so I was a newbie at this.
This was fun.
- I like it.
Listen, I think you could
have a lot of success
turning this into a YouTube channel
as well for what you're doing, man.
- I may just have to do that.
I may just have to do that.
So, anyways, well, hey,
I appreciate it, Evan.
Take care and hopefully we'll
catch up soon, my friend.
- Thanks for the love, man.
It's been awesome.
- Alright, brother. See ya man.
- Alright, that was good.
- Cool, buddy. Excellent.
That's it? We're not live anymore?
- No, no, we're still live on my channel,
but your thing is off.
- I got it, got it.
- That's good.
And then, quickly, for
people who are watching
and they want to find out
about Entrepreneur Hour,
where's the best place to find it?
- Yeah, you can go to
chrismichaelharris.com/show.
That'll take you directly to the iTunes.
It is on iTunes, Stitcher, you name it.
It's everywhere.
And then, my website is
chrismichaelharris.com.
We got a bunch of cool,
like free resources,
whatever phase your business is in,
like if you're just starting out,
we've got the ultimate start-up checklist.
And then, if you're raising capital,
which is kind of the
clients that I work with,
most of them are in cap-raise mode,
so I've got some tips for, you know,
I've got a Rolodex of over,
almost over 1,000 investors
around the country, so a
lot of helping them connect
with the investors, how to
prepare for fundraising,
make sure they've got
their books in order,
make sure they've got the
infrastructure to scale
because scaling's great
but you've got to have
those foundational pieces in place.
So, a lot of cool resources
there they can check out
and then obviously follow the show
because we've got some
awesome guests like yourself
that come on on a weekly basis.
Like I said, we just had Daymond John,
I've had some really,
New York Times best-selling
author Michael E. Gerber,
you name it.
So we've had some really awesome guests.
It's been a really powerful tool.
Honestly, you said something
that really resonated with me,
when you said that a lot of times,
you're doing the videos that you do
and you're learning
just as much sometimes.
And honestly, I feel like
my level of knowledge
in terms of entrepreneurship
has multiplied exponentially
since I started the podcast
because I have to dig deep.
And it's one thing to learn something
and something else to teach it.
You have to learn it in a new way
to be able to teach it to somebody else.
It's been a really powerful tool for me
to learn as well and
grow as an entrepreneur
and just connect with people
and interact with them
and stuff like that.
So man, it's been awesome.
I really have enjoyed it.
- It's obvious too, Chris.
I mean, 'cause the questions you ask,
like, you're genuinely curious about them.
- No, sure.
- It's not just like,
oh, well, but you know
what, a lot of podcasts too,
look okay, here are
10 questions, go.
- It's fluff.
- So it's obvious that you're learning
and you're enjoying it
and you pick your guests
with a reason,
and I'm excited, man.
I might have to start getting
into listening to the podcast
just to get Entrepreneur
Hour on my playlist.
- Either that man, or I'm
a have to start doing video
for you to start consuming.
- There we go, yes.
Okay, you know what, that's a deal.
If you start a YouTube
channel, I will subscribe.
- Alright, well, I'm going to
look for your lead on it, man
because I have no idea how
to start a YouTube channel.
- Happy to help, dude.
This is it.
And then, when is this episode going up?
- Okay, so right now, we've got,
I think you're fifth
or sixth in the queue,
so we're looking at probably
the last week of February.
So about three weeks, we're
going to go live with this one.
- Cool, alright.
- So we'll ping you guys,
obviously, it'll be on social and things,
so just be on the look out for it.
- Yeah, send it to me, and
we'll share it off too.
Anyway, awesome.
Guys, thank you for watching.
Chris, thank you for the time, man.
Good luck with the show.
I really appreciate you asking
those amazing questions.
Continue to believe everyone,
and we'll see you soon.
- Alright bro, bye bye.